courtesy of Old Spice is a guy who we
had on this show way back when he was
that guy that everybody thought who
looks like gronke wears Gronk's number
now the way before he became Travis
Kelce that's so in other words I feel
like the Rich Eisen show discovered this
man Travis Kelce here on the Rich Eisen
show is that a fair assessment Travis
you say I'll take it fair Rich I think
it's okay it's alright if you don't
think it's if it's fair I can take it I
can handle it oh no for sure rich I give
you friend in that regard you definitely
found found me first and what had you
read kind of found the person than you
thought oh is that right I mean when was
the first time you met with Reid was
that a combine was that where it was
there something like that what was it
was well actually I first met him he has
emotional Jason my brother played for
Andy and Philly and when the University
of Cincinnati played temple my senior
year it was at the Eagle Stadium so I
don't read actually came down I shook
his hand and met him there and then the
next time I talked to him was I was
doing the draft isn't it amazing
I mean life his life comes at you fast
it's really strange how things work out
and now you've got this kid in the
huddle and Patrick mahomes did you see
this coming Travis um yeah I mean I I
saw glimpses of it I mean when there's
not a there's not a pass that goes 80
yards and practice that you don't just
like hey know this guy could slay it
doesn't go unnoticed so it's uh knowing
that and then the confidence that he
brings into the huddle and and the
confidence he brings on the practice
field I think that that's the overall
indicator they get he can do it give me
an example of the confidence um just
priest I've read I mean his his first
touchdown pass to the Tyriq Hill it was
a run pass option you can either hand it
off or he can make a read during the
play and throw it to Tyreke and sure
enough the window was small it was a
bang-bang thing to where he had to do it
fairly fast essentially and he just
roped it right on a on a line right sits
high reach chest and
sure enough Tyriq typical house so I
mean that was for him to kind of pre
snaps to you to see the defense know
where to go with it and to have enough
confidence in his arm to fit it in a
small window I mean that's when you see
it on film it's it's something special
so how do you temper the excitement
because I know the fans can't I mean
every Chiefs fan I know is out of their
skull excited about this three weeks
we're all trying to deal with it the
exact same way I mean everybody on this
team is aesthetic right now I mean the
energy level during the games is through
the rules everybody's getting a piece of
the pie he's out there slinging it
around we're all excited for everybody
else's success and it's just um it's
something we haven't been a part of so
it's something new something that will
have to grow with and try and keep
gauging throughout the season but I mean
it's uh right now it's it's sky-high
right Travis Kelce here on the Rich
Eisen show and your chemistry with him
looks like you've been playing with him
for ten years I mean how does somebody
work on that I mean I've always kind of
had the mentality of a backyard football
myself and I mean guys Pat it is finest
I mean I think the touchdown pass to
Chris Conley that everyone said kind of
opened their eyes on that throw in the
in the end zone where you scrambling
around for a second that's when that's
one that's at his best when he can just
go out there play back their football
when the play breaks down he finds guys
that are open make some W crows it's
just it's a fun fun deal place so Travis
I don't if you heard the latest news the
latest news is that members of the
competition committee are getting
together if not this week then maybe
later on to discuss the past roughing
the passer penalties that have been
called right now I'd love to get your
sense of things as a football player
again the NFL is doing this for player
safety they are not doing this to piss
people off they're doing it to try and
make the game safer for quarterbacks and
thus obviously you understand how
valuable a quarterback is we just had
pretty much the first five minutes of a
conversation on that front what what are
your thoughts on on what's going on with
the roughing the passer call I think I
think it's a pretty much a consensus
which is why they're having these talks
already this early in the season it's
changing the game it's changing the
outcome of games I mean look at the
Vikings Green Bay game one play that
highly under question whether or not it
was a penalty or not he's um change the
outcome in the game and it's a it's
unfortunate because I mean a lot of guys
if not all of them get into this game
because it's a violent game because they
can literally abuse the guy in front of
them and it's it's it's sad to see where
this game kind of is on the road to go
and hopefully that we can get it changed
to where you know it's still exciting
for the fans and for everyone to watch
it's still exciting to play and at the
same time I'm the whole safety thing I
mean I know what I'm getting into
going out on the field is it's not it
was never meant to be a safe game they
had the pads help it and helmets help it
and I think that's the best way to keep
it safe is the key by making these
helmets um kind of concussion proofer or
along that line it's uh it's just um
it's it's tough to put it on the the
refs whistle it's it's hard it's hard to
put it in their hands on whether or not
something should be called or not it's
um instead of just going out there
letting the game do its thing I know
I've only have a couple minutes left
with you as you're on a tour here for
for Old Spice but one last question on
this is if they decided to make a change
in the middle of the season would you
have a problem with that because I'm
already hearing that they gotta wait
they can't do something midseason
because it's already been called a
certain way um I think everyone at this
point we kind of be alright with that
all right just this one time we can let
it slide just in the middle of the
season making a play making a change in
how they're calling these games because
it's a it's it's such a consensus right
now that nobody really appreciates this
hmm
so alright let's talk about the beard
care collection we talked about it with
your brother yesterday I got to be
honest with you I mean the beard that
he's got going on looks like it needs
more care that said though
you you you can't argon with like the
elite beard Travis yeah am i wrong
without a doubt yes I mean Jason's
always kind of had the man cave beard
since I've been growing it I'd like to
keep a little bit more care to it you
know I used the beard oils and then I
actually watched my beard Jason probably
doesn't do that hmm
and it's uh it's I mean it's in the
entire package I mean everything that
you need to maintain a lovely beard as
old Spice's gotta for you mm-hmm and in
terms of the beard though I would think
yours does require more maintenance it
looks like you're more maintained when
it comes without a doubt actually I
didn't enjoy maintaining a beard that's
it has always got to a certain extent oh
my god I need to cut this thing because
it is itching it's uh
it's going in a completely different
direction I wanted to but since I've
been using old spy stuff in it it's easy
to maintain I mean you just wash it you
throw the oil in it did skate there if
you want to shape it up just using some
of the beard balm you know that works
too if I wanted to create a Kelcey depth
chart last one for your Travis a Kelsey
depth chart on a skilled position player
how would I
how would that depth chart look right
now on a skill position on a skill
design which I would say Tyriq Hill
Sammy Watkins are one and two whatever
no I meant you a Jason a Kelsey skilled
position oh oh um I'm not sure I know
what you're asking but I'm gonna go
ahead considers himself a skilled
position player Travis Jason said I mean
I'll tell you what as always he's always
been helping athletes I mean if you
watch him out there he runs just about
as well laterally speed wise as a
skilled guy would run so I mean I guess
I guess I can say that Jason's
definitely got some skill here go that's
the brother aspect of it Travis Congrats
on the first three games look forward to
chatting down the line when we're not
just talking beards and things and and
penalties and whatnot look forward to
chatting more
always rich you know a tickety the fact
that you same to you
Travis Kelce @t Kelsey the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience